[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday august 11th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
on wednesday samsung revealed the latest
versions of its foldable smartphones the
galaxy z fold 4 which becomes the size
of a small tablet when opened and the
more compact galaxy z flip for
for customers who may be growing weary
of how connected they are to their
devices the company has a pretty simple
pitch here's kim swanson's from
samsung's marketing and sales team at
wednesday's launch event describing the
perks of foldable phones
they change smartphone behavior shifting
how we use our devices and giving us
more control over what we're doing in
the moment when you open your phone you
can really immerse yourself in focus and
the simple act of closing your device
signals to your friends that they have
your undivided attention
but they also have drawbacks compared to
other smartphones their screens are more
delicate and their price tags are hefty
still samsung isn't the only company
betting that foldables are the way of
the future
joining me to discuss why is our
personal tech reporter dalvin brown
hi dalvin thanks for joining me thanks
for having me
so let's start with kind of why samsung
does think more consumers are going to
want to buy their their foldable phones
what changes has it made to to make
these phones these new generation of
their foldables more appealing
yeah so four years after
launching its first foldable samsung's
new devices look a lot like the old ones
from the outside but what's been changed
is the ruggedness so samsung
really focused a lot of attention on the
crease that's created when opening and
closing its foldable phones there's also
a panel that protects the screen and
samsung attached it with
with a better adhesive so that it
wouldn't peel off as it has in previous
models so really samsung focused
primarily on the durability of these new
devices
okay so this is the fourth generation of
the phone they're improving durability
but how have sales been so far and i
guess how is samsung expecting them to
be
yeah so samsung says that foldables are
here to stay and is doubling down on
them
consumers have been buying these phones
more and more each year
last year samsung's foldables were the
most popular
foldable devices in the globe but
samsung is also the largest smartphone
maker but it's also important to put
those numbers into context so foldable
phones represent less than one percent
of overall smartphones
in the market today and so while
they are becoming more popular among a
subset of users they're still just a
drop in the bucket in terms of like
overall smartphone sales
what about the competition for making it
i mean you mentioned that samsung was
the the biggest seller of foldables but
is it the only one
samsung is not the only one there are
some other notable names xiaomi oppo and
lenovo's motorola
also have foldable phones
and
apple holds patents for foldable phones
so there may be one in the future
so right now samsung's fold and the flip
they both have pretty steep price tags
is competition going to affect that
yeah so just like with
ordinary smartphones that we're all
familiar with foldables are expected to
come down in price over time
samsung initially launched its fold
at two thousand dollars and that price
has dropped about two hundred dollars
since then its galaxy z flip has dropped
by three hundred eighty dollars since
its first launch so
we're expecting prices to continue to
fall some analysts told me that they
expect that foldables will always be
premium so we may never see a 400
foldable just because the parts and
components are so are so expensive but
also as the price comes down more
consumers may be interested in
purchasing one
why bother with a foldable i mean i can
understand that for a user there's this
kind of nice convenience of having a
slightly smaller phone when you want it
to be small and bigger when you want it
to be bigger
but from
the makers standpoint this seems
complicated it's expensive you've got to
get people to shell out a lot more money
to buy them
why bother going this route
well if you look at it most smartphones
look the same today they are black glass
boxes with a couple cameras on the back
and year after year that's what
consumers get so
what smartphone makers are looking
to do
is break away from that and
differentiate themselves from the
competition and so what foldable phones
do or more flexible screens do is they
allow companies a chance to
create something new that consumers
haven't seen
and to put their own spin on it okay but
when do these foldables become fixtures
of the market i mean when is this
actually going to change kind of the the
broader smartphone market and not just
be something that samsung is offering
yeah so analysts that i spoke to said
that foldables may never overtake the
bar shaped smartphones we're
all accustomed to today
but they do speak to something larger
which is just like creating more nimble
screens or maybe even rollable
screens that pull out from a device and
allows you to sort of double the space
of your phone without having to add a
hinge to it
so they may never be as popular as the
devices that we're familiar with today
but they are certainly picking up in
popularity and a subset of consumers are
noticing
all right that's our personal tech
reporter dalvin brown thanks for joining
us dalvin thanks for having me as always
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you